welcome back to another episode of the
wind-down today we are joined by
Alexander Hoshi plays my love interest
and jury to discuss Loki tripping this
was a big episode for Andrew O'Malley
what do you think this trip says about
their relationship I mean I don't think
Emily uh I don't think they take family
lightly either of them so the fact that
somebody's meeting someone else's family
just like things being pretty serious
between these two people my Andrews
journey yeah I think Andrew Andrews been
confronted I think for the first time
Andrews sort of been really challenged
by a strong personality and relationship
so this is the first time when he's been
lat oh okay I need to contribute yeah in
some way that makes me uncomfortable and
so I think mainly that's been being
vulnerable like you know just being an
Asian man and being raised the way he
was talking about things that don't make
him feel strongly make him feel it's
really a really difficult for him what
do you think sort of going through
Maui's head during her arguing with
Victor about her overreacting to the
towel lady it's it's I think it's the
first time that Molly's had to defend
her existence to somebody who is of
Andrews side of the relationship so it's
like the first time that Molly's had to
explain what being black is like to
Victor and Andrew is kind of on the side
but also at the same time is just trying
to understand where both sides are
coming from and I think in that moment
what he was trying to do by trying to
defuse a situation wasn't actually
helpful because he actually made Molly
feel more isolated episode out of the
country what was it like I think it was
infused I think a new energy into this
show to also take a show that on papers
about you know these two black women
that live in a very specific part of LA
and take them and put them in the sea
but people travel and take this show and
not just show you know obviously us
filming there is one thing to see black
people you know you know in front of the
camera behind the camera out of the
country you know filming a television
show but I think also it does a lot even
on screen to see that because we do
travel though
no Issa I mean how was that for you on
your side let's go three more but I do
want to talk about just the presence
that Issa has on this trip so I think
even though Issa was not appearing in
this episode Issa definitely featured
heavily feel like it's affected and only
so much because Issa and monie that's
just such a strong presence in each
other's lives I do wonder if the fight
with Issa hadn't happened and if she
didn't have that burden on her trip if
she would have gone so hard on victor
victor was being a bit of a dick Victor
was a dick for sure yeah I think Victor
was the victim of displacement of rancor
and I think that's what's interesting
about episode six and seven even though
they're not in each of those episodes
their presence is felt that's how strong
these two women are each of those laws
and then how much by them not dealing
with it it's still a presence they have
to face in some way and so I think
that's what's great about the end with
Yvonne is like I have to sort of start
to deal with this when do you feel like
it's right to react or to let it go
speaking as myself or what I would like
myself to do reacts react all day so the
towel from the towel lady to the fight
and they just leave well I need to I
need to work on actively look I have my
own doctor Rhonda and she helps me I I
react a lot I feel like reacting might
not be the issue overreacting is an
issue reacting is on the issue yeah but
I think when you react its importance
it's like find a way to maintain
capacity to listen okay well we can't
thank you enough for joining us this
week be sure to join us next week for a
new episode of no
mine down Cheers
[Music]
you